I've got Parker Parker how are you hey
I'm doing well Chris how are you oh I'm
focused - not finished my friend how can
I help you hey I just had a question I'm
24 and I'm about at baby Step five no
children on single my household income
is about 120 to 300 a year I have about
a hundred and one invested in about
thirty-four saved and I was just kind of
kind of wondering what what's the next
step and I'm looking at a house where
should I invest that okay very good
Parker where did you at this age you're
24 years old where did you learn about
money you know I my parents were pretty
good but I joined the Navy and learned a
lot there and that's that's where I am
now I don't have any debt because of
that that is fantastic well thank you
for your service my friend how much
longer are you gonna be enlisted I'm
naturally out I got injured so I'm
working as an engineer now okay
fantastic
and where you are right now is that
where you plan to be for the next five
years or so the next five years or so
yeah I'm going to grad school but works
paying for that as well okay good and I
say that because with the way you've
worked through you got yourself out of
debt you've got a fully funded emergency
fund and you're investing you know at 24
years old already have 101 thousand
dollars put away for your retirement is
phenomenal this next step Parker is
going to be huge especially as you look
to buy a home I want to encourage you to
to make sure that you're thinking
clearly on what it is you're looking to
buy but I want you to be intentional
with saving for a down payment so I want
you to have a minimum a 10% to put down
as a down payment so this would be where
you were just in your money market
account you'll start to stick some money
I would love for you to go into it with
20% down and here's why there's a thing
out there called PMI it's private
mortgage insurance is he don't talk
about this anywhere else okay but the
reality is is what this private mortgage
insurance does is protect the bank it
doesn't protect you at all and in fact
it adds one hundred fifty to three
hundred dollars a month to your payment
so if you can go in with the 20% down
payment
you won't have to deal with that PMI at
all now you're single you don't have
kids you got a strong income there's no
reason you can't get to 20% but I also
want you to be aware so buying a home is
a business physician you don't get
caught up in emotions you want to see
clearly you want to make a two-year
decision I call it you want to make a
decision about the type of home you buy
right now and you want to look back on
it in two years and you want to be glad
that you made that decision now listen
to me a two-year decision requires that
you pull up out of this situation you
don't make an emotional decision you
want to make a business decision and so
Parker I encourage you don't buy your
dream house this is your first house and
trust me you will meet somebody and get
married later and they're gonna show you
why that house you wanted wasn't right
anyway so you want to slow down but you
want to go into it with your eyes wide
open I'm proud of you young man at your
age and your stage you're ahead of the
game
and you're doing a fantastic job stay
focused my friend you are definitely not
finished